combines bottom and rubbish into one
world a brilliant the sinct translation
this is a game where written text means
a lot and the slide is mistake can and
health affected herpretation of
organization
at this time Frust the find it
againer
in English
surprise so in red and
Seasons  am going to read the little
japanes text
original translation Seas nothing about
this and to life Fundy is translations
from trying to make connections throw
video
and free translation companies working
on the translation of Dark Souls 26
in the really good and
action
translation and only the translation  of
the sea containe summer of the world
translations in the game of
Kings demonform da sind have a name
it still the old time king or his body
at least by Quinn Soul from Dark Souls
one and turned Tomato Earth no new
green soul is a part of  the old I'm King
Concrete
his Mountain Earth Form when you kill
your time King in you Game pass the old
King so what the sound of the never this
is the solo the Queen just like
from Dark Souls one thing is er in
Germany's it's hold  the soul of one with
name is the text
offers say what there summer with the
serpents and summer this green so
happens that canvanianly for the mystery
of the law the japanase text Reviews
that the one US name is for beden is
the same is the one  Hill soul is of the
neverbot which that the one with the old
time King metal is
Winx
disrupts let's talk about the
witch tower problem [ __ ] up
the name
more implications and the world the
witch does in Japanese
fictional sentence and the life of the
time
possibilities a many  times
coding to a translator die Souls open
sick blood of the code maybe even
posässing the wilder
presented in Dark Souls oneplication the
this say that alone
oh this
is thing
definitions the English translation
in the giant memory once
around the control
slow thinking is
memories internations that  is something
you might diversify from fighting with
the giants you might learn from them and
learn to resonate
presence in the English translation
from
of the king with the join and statements
it triggers alfight with the Sandra and
possibles the movement of the Gollums so
of the giant  are beautiful with the golden
some hell and do the react to someone
her
resides you know this is the you
and less WE dies Japanese descriptions
also English texture Garding the
throne in makes sound like some magical
lighthum that grand cell wishes like a
magic lab and wall  I can do think these
minds to be trouble
important everyone things the think of
text Station
okay das impossible Locations because
there projection the
people to leaders Hill the Dragon
early the here the dragons words not the
angel Dragons was Hits my canization
speaking a complete different
becomes  that
the move
it move again long as the sick is to
Livecam
talking about the player it's a
crap easy talking expected
host is the one influencing the guy so
the cherried Bing the executional makes
the Royal record of thirty whatever
thatmans is the red Kings Test
you to speak Quinn Alana this quality
in Japanese which doubles as referend
to the stain on your reputation Ohio
she's filty down to the very call of the
Bing harvest Valley isn't Action
harvestment
gathering in Valley of the every King of
the white King
white if  that
something
days
on the story
information in the game Birgit cry ivory
that a pistiv Information in future DLC
wo camert that will make my video
obsolete
just i want to get this right the first
time I do the people confused wirecover
the evil of the Queens  and over the
story of the sun and
the rest of the game the rest of the
game is in like that it goes to the
pent on the know it we got from
action
I think maybe I could be my wron
exactly I need to be someone
and go and everything you've Danone